si vous avez un problème n'hésitez pas à
payer soit les secours soient vos
directement votre fille d'accord donner
des conseils prêté une oreille attentive
depuis le début de la canicule ryan est
aux petits soins des seniors plaisir oit
il fait partie du dispositif et yes plus
yvelines étudiants seniors on les
appelle pour compte de leurs nouvelles
pour savoir s'ils respectent
correctement badge les gestes en fait à
appliquer en période de canicule c'est à
dire boire régulièrement manger fermer
ses volets garder la maison fraîche on
entre guillemets se sentir très bien au
service maintien à domicile de plaisir
on joue à deux à trois fois par semaine
les seniors ils sont plus d'une centaine
à bénéficier du dispositif
ça rajoute à leurs inquiétudes quoi
parce qu'on cumule là effectivement de
une pandémie une période de forte
chaleur ça fait beaucoup de choses si
une personne ne répond pas on va pas
forcément ça alerter immédiatement parce
qu'elle peut ne pas être chez elle par
contre on va repasser
un autre appel l'après midi ou lendemain
matin si elle ne répond pas on a aussi
recensé des contacts soient des enfants
ou des voisins
la chaleur touche toutes les générations
malgré quelques gouttes de pluie cet
après midi le thermomètre affiche encore
34 degrés alors on cherche à se
rafraîchir
comme ici à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines 18 jeux d'eau sont
disponibles pour faire baisser un peu la
température l'affluence est de mise pour
profiter d'une eau à 20 degrés avec elle
a calculé bien joué ici ça m'aurait peut
se défouler était bien vert s'allume et
16e go et on voulait y aller
l'idée des jeux d'eau c'était était
simple c'est convivial c'est pratique ça
reste une activité à proximité depuis
une grosse semaine en gros et l'épisode
caniculaire
on attend vraiment les quota maximum en
milieu de journée
très rapidement avec les fortes chaleurs
pour maintenir une qualité d'eau qui
soit que soit la meilleure possible
on a été obligé de diminuer un petit peu
ce côté là 475 personnes aujourd'hui
météo france maintient les yvelines et
la région ile de france en vigilance
rouge jusqu'au mercredi 12 août